no I I once nearly had to beat up my
son's gym teacher why you know cuz he
opened his [__] mouth and he had a
come into him you know my son Max right
when he was in Middle School he was
heavier right okay and I took him see I
would do things to help my kids without
saying we're doing this to help you take
off weight I don't do it like that I
just take them and and I would take Max
to the beach to Beach right and he would
run with me on the beach okay and then
he didn't know why he was running he
liked it he enjoyed it running near the
ocean you would say Max come here and
then you you would run away and he would
chase you no we would jog on the beach
right then we'd go to Gold's Venice okay
where he would see these guys working
out these real like Champions Real
bodybuilders and then he got on a
treadmill and he didn't get off that was
his thing he loved the treadmill and he
lost 25 lbs that year and I took him to
my trainer who trained Stallone for all
the Rocky movies his name was George
piptick so George knows everything he's
even in one of the Rockies the one with
the Russian he like he's at the cabin
chopping wood he he trains Sly for the
Rockies the rambos so he knows how to
get somebody in shape well he knows what
you can and can't do and Max was young
he was only 13 so he goes okay you could
do this you could do this but you don't
want him doing this cuz it could it
could hurt him right so he taught him
okay so max comes down in in loses all
this weight so all of a sudden he comes
home he
failed uh Jim for not wearing the right
sweatshirt in the gym class and he
didn't write this report about exercise
so I'm like oh doesn't the teacher say
you know I never like got backup you
know really from their mom she would
never that that was one of the problems
you know like as my career got bigger so
he didn't do his homework so he failed
so why would you go beat up the teacher
no no no I I didn't initially want to
hit him okay I wanted to talk reasonably
to the guy okay so I sit down with them
like Indian style you know where you
cross your legs Native American whatever
you want to call them crisscross
applesauce yeah crisscross
applesauce where we are today and you
crisscross applesauce spoons in the bowl
okay that's what we did so with with the
gym teacher yeah on on the floor but how
do you even show up and say Hey you sit
down no I want to talk to you so he goes
all right let's sit on the floor you
know the teacher did okay so I go look I
go my kid is very upset that you failed
them because he's been working very hard
you know to to bring get his weight off
right you know and he's done that goes
well you know if the whole class is
wearing a gray sweatshirt and he comes
in with a white sweatshirt and I'm going
so that's why you fail a kid you don't
take a look and go look what he's
done well he said to me he didn't want
to write about exercise he wanted to do
it and I go and what's the problem with
that right I go isn't that what Jim
class is all about we do the jumping
jacks we don't write about them right
you know so you know I am from a place
where things get heated Brooklyn right
you know so what happened so he goes
well I I can't change that great I go
why it's [__] Jim you know I go I'm
sitting here just trying to talk to you
man if you had a kid you know that did
that wouldn't you you pass that kid you
know you're knocking him him like his
self-esteem down like you know he's
feeling bad about what you did cuz it's
the one thing he's done this year to do
something with himself now I'm on my
feet you know is he still crisscross
apples no now he's up and I go pal
listen because I was looked at because
you know me and my girlfriend always
talk about that I was really the first
cancel culture only I wasn't it they
didn't call it cancel culture they tried
to knock me down but I came through it
all right and in this day and age I go I
could say what I want I was
grandfathered in you know when you see
all this cancel stuff but they looked at
me at his school like oh here comes the
animal you know what I mean this is what
I had to deal with you know and so the
guy's like getting in my face and
finally he sees I'm dead serious like
you want to go let's go you know like I
I can't even play this California game
anymore you know and he goes I'll tell
you what I'll
do if he wears the right sweatshirt this
is what it's over he goes I'll give him
a passing grade at the end of the school
year okay so I thanked him and I left
right you know and but I would go
through that you
know
he